oftentimes people think that creating
big change means actually taking big
steps toward that big change and what we
find in our research is that small acts
are often times more effective at
creating that big change that if you
have sort of micro goals that lead to
this larger goal and you take those
small acts those are the context in
which people tend to be more effective
we find there's four design
characteristics around you know the
phenomenon where small excrete big
change one is when the act is quite
small any of a single focus goal the
second is when the act is unusual or
unexpected and grabs people's attention
the third is when the act is highly
engaging and it makes people sort of
lean in and look and the fourth is when
the act is very actionable and so others
can participate in that small act and
when you have these four design
characteristics going for you you find
that individuals are much more likely to
both perform small acts that can create
big change and also be successful in a
larger goals they might have
you